the miracles of team play are not always
accomplished by the cheers of crowds for
instance consider mrs. Smith her
Majesty the American housewife
about to take part in an everyday
miracle communication oh don't be
silly I'm just telephoning the butcher
of course but let's see what that means
thus with one finger mrs. Smith puts into action
of fabulously intricate and precisely coordinated
system and is mrs. Smith impressed a little
over awed by the magic she has wrought magic
Fiddlesticks why it's just the simplest thing in
the world the simplest thing in the world - mrs.
Smith yes yet it takes one of the most complex
systems in the world to achieve that simplicity
on her telephone book is a familiar emblem and
the symbol of a high standard of industrial
teamwork - mrs. Smith it means simply the
telephone company and she knows the telephone
company in a way she's met the courteous little
lady behind the tellers desk on several occasions
and she likes her she knows the girl who answers
her puzzling questions and then there's that nice
person on long distance who was so clever in
locating mr. Smith in Springfield one of the
telephone supervisors is a member of her garden
club and last spring when that tree limb tore
down the wires why some men from the telephone
company got everything fixed in almost no time
yes indeed mrs. Smith knows the telephone company
yet there is so much she doesn't see so much that
is concealed behind the scenes here's a group of
new employees players on the team going through
blackboard drill with their coach that's listen
every day the nation makes more than 100 million
telephone calls for business or social contact in
trivial matters or critical emergency everybody
turns to the telephone to talk half a block for
halfway around the world to get all those calls
through is a big job and to us the most important
job in the world it's a real job for the team of
more than a half million Bell System men and women
and it's a job of teamwork between the three units
that make up the bell system teamwork between the
operating telephone company Western Electric the
supply unit of the Bell System and the scientific
resources of Bell Laboratories three names and
three services coordinated by the parent company
AT&T working toward the common goal of more and
better telephone service at lowest possible cost
working together and working for whom why for
mrs. Smith of course to trace that pattern of team
play let's take a familiar example her telephone
came into being in Bell Telephone laboratories the
largest single organization in the world devoted
exclusively to communications research of course
what goes on here would be somewhat baffling to
mrs. Smith in Bell Laboratories scientists
and technicians are constantly improving on
the past and probing into the future mrs. Smith
may understand little of electronics and nuclear
physics for that matter she doesn't have to but
she would be at least surprised and perhaps a
little flattered to know how important she is in
the eyes of this distinguished scientific group
she accepts the styling of her telephone as a
matter of course little realizing how many designs
were developed and considered before the selection
of hers as having the classic dignity and grace
to fit tastefully into her home well the studies
made to be sure that it would fit comfortably and
easily into her hand and the hands of thousands
of her neighbors for the research required to
assure the most efficient speaking and listening
position recognize this probably not but this
is a truly all-american portrait incorporating
accurate measurements of the heads and faces of
all types of mr. and mrs. Smith in America being
human mrs. Smith probably will be a bit careless
or impatient at times so in the laboratory
experimental designs are put through a carefully
calculated program of abuse day in and day out
thousands upon thousands of times pre proving
the durability and reliability of the telephone
mechanism so accustomed is Her Majesty to seeing
her telephone in this compact simple form that
she'd probably be a little shocked to discover
that it actually contains nearly 500 parts and
in no industry even in watchmaking our standards
of precision more critical than those required in
telephone manufacture yet although often subjected
to abuse that would ruin our watch the telephone
is expected to survive and perform perfectly
and it does because the equipment is designed to
stand up under these rough conditions of use not
only designed but thoroughly tested and because
mrs. Smith telephone is the result of the teaming
up of the development and production engineers
of a Bell System for a telephone would be only
a laboratory achievement unless translated into
quantity production this is the task of Western
Electric matching technological progress with
facilities for multiplying the laboratory design
by the millions from hundreds of piece parts skill
figures build up sub assemblies conveyors keep the
job moving to the casual observer the entire
production process is bewilderingly complex
but actually it is coordinated into a steady
consecutive flow here every six seconds a new
Bell Telephone is born completely assembled
tested and proved representing the highest
coordination of Science and Industry and yet
alone the telephone is utterly useless for
the instrument itself represents only six percent
of all the plant and equipment needed to provide
telephone service this service might be likened
to an iceberg there's a lot more to it than you
can see before mrs. Smith's telephone comes to
light it must be connected with the nerve system
of the telephone network here telephone wire
is produced thousands of miles of it every day
first scarcely recognizable but wait a 60 inch
billet is brought to cherry red heat then under
ponderous rolls the billet gradually changes
shape now it's a luminous snake constantly
stretching and extending smaller and smaller
longer and longer until that original 5 foot
do it of copper will eventually be transformed
into 2160 miles of precisely accurate finished
wire watch the giant cabling machines in action
the wire now insulated with paper races from a
battery of spinning reels to become cable units
these same cable units are later joined together
to form cable core after drying giant presses give
a heavy protective coat of enduring lead or if the
cable is designed for underwater use an additional
sheath of steel wire armor is provided to protect
the thousands of vital voice ways it contains
yes it's just telephone wire but in a broader
sense it is a lifeline of communication nerve
center of thousands of lines of voice ways is the
telephone central office keeping telephone traffic
moving swiftly and finally making central office
equipment is a huge job it is no mass-production
project however for each switchboard must be
specially engineered to fit the specific central
office for which it is intended whether it's the
central office of some quiet village or one of the
central office switchboards for a great city every
job is accustomed and perhaps that's the best way
to describe telephone manufacture custom work on
a quantity scale altogether the 23 factories and
the 112 thousand men and women of Western Electric
in 18 cities produce more than 150 thousand
different piece parts which make up some 40,000
separate finished items of telephone apparatus
some are familiar at first glance most are utterly
unknown even to those who depend upon them every
day for example vacuum fuels naturally most of us
associate such tubes with radio receivers but
actually they were developed first to provide
better telephone service and today thousands of
Western electric vacuum tubes and a great variety
of sizes are used to do many different telephone
jobs many are used for amplifying circuits
boosting voice power so that mrs. Smith can talk
across the country as clearly as around the corner
with these tubes to help her she can talk across
the oceans around the world tubes also furnish the
invisible link between lonely island communities
and the outside world precision craftsmanship
that's Western Electric production take the
making of crystals for radio and telephone
circuits there's not much to look at but to do
their job some crystals must be ground to within
a millionth of an inch must by brake 50 million
times a second others are accurate to one part in
700 million if a clock were to run continuously
with that accuracy it would not gain or lose
more than a minute in a thousand years precision
craftsmanship on our broad scale not only must
every piece of equipment operate perfectly as
an individual part but each telephone must be
capable of working in harmony with each one of
the millions of other telephones in the bell
system to which mrs. Smith they want to talk for
Western Electric is the supply unit for the barrel
system operating telephone companies which link
the nation in an overall communications network
to attain this uncompromising precision and
uniformity production quality control inspection
and testing have become a science in themselves
to one accustomed to consider micrometers as the
last word in accuracy the new order of electronic
gauging seems strange indeed the sweep of a needle
on a dial the flickering pattern of a light wave
on an oscilloscope the squeal of a beat frequency
may not seem very significant but they represent
standards of measurement actually far beyond the
power of human senses probably few products of
man can be so critically judged so frequently
challenged for in a very real sense this is
living equipment to realize what that means
think of a bell telephone exchange and even a
small village on duty 24 hours a day every day
bearing a responsibility in which it must not fail
or the repeater station often remote an unattended
on-the-job area Mandurah stepping up the power
of the voice ways and relays across the miles
between how good is good enough in establishing
production quality standards for these vital
voice ways obviously there can be only one answer
only a standard which becomes ever increasingly
critical as new methods of quality judgement
are devised precision craftsmanship on our broad
scale a responsibility which has grown in Western
Electric through more than six decades as a member
of the telephone service team yet vital as is this
role of apparatus builder it is only part of the
Western electrics job as supply unit of the Bell
System supply unit maybe the term would be more
meaningful if we called it logistics that's what
we called it in war good logistics meant simply
getting there fastest with the mostest in the
telephone system we call it supply by any name
it's the scientific scheduling of materials
manufacturing processes and distribution to
anticipate mrs. Smith's telephone requirements
it's the teamwork by which the vast production
output required by the telephone companies
in 17 operating areas may be channelled to
those points when and where needed with the
exact precision of a touchdown play that's
Western electrics John a job that begins with
a purchase of basic raw materials and extends
to a long list of supplies essential to a great
nationwide industry all the world contributes
its treasures to telephone service mountains of
copper copper for wires and tons of rubber to
cover them and some you'd scarcely imagined gold
24-karat gold yes indeed and many other metals
even more precious go into the endless millions
of electrical contact all these and many more
right down to the paper clips and typewriter
ribbon and thousands of other items needed to
run the telephone plan and this responsibility is
one requiring more than merely due consideration
for quality service and fair price supplementing
its own vast manufacturing facilities Western
Electric buys for the telephone companies many
millions of dollars worth of telephone material
from thousands of other manufacturers located all
over the country to assure that this equipment
will measure up to Bell System standards
a staff is constantly employed inspecting
suppliers products and gauging quality with eyes
just as critical as those in Western electrics
home plans to ensure that factory standards of
performance carry over to the point of operations
the equipment for each central office must be
installed and tested initially by the men who
know it best teams of Western Electric installers
they may be assigned here a week a month or a year
and the individual telephone companies gain
a technical service at a savings reflected in
the cost to mrs. Smith but when the last line
is completed the last connection tested this
flying squadron will go on to a new job perhaps
in the next town perhaps hundreds of miles away
key control points in this entire complex pattern
of peacetime logistics are the merchandize
departments of the main factory locations
and 29 western electric distributing houses
strategically located to serve the Bell Telephone
companies here are maintained stocks of apparatus
and supplies source of a never-ending stream with
every item on a definite schedule reels of cable
for a mining community over the ridge a dozen
a hundred telephones for an apartment building
to be completed next month apparatus for a new
exchange now which will reach capacity operation
in three years all these in the thousand and one
day-to-day items are in constant demand by the
operating companies engaged in linking America
by voice ways a constant stream moving out where
and when needed and to maintain ample stocks in
readiness without the wasteful pile up of over
supply is a job demanding its own hiya strategy a
large part of which is anticipation how many Poles
how many wires will snap in the next winter sleep
storms how many instruments will need repair and
replacement all about growth of new industries
shifts in population new communities which will
require enlargement of telephone services one two
or five years hence the answers to these questions
come to Western Electric through Bell System team
play so that efficient and economical production
and distribution are taken in stride but there are
events that no one can foresee as when disaster
strikes and whole communities are cut off from
the world yet even such emergency are met with
their own special tactics Communications must be
restored first so in the matter of hours equipment
is on its way by train by truck by plane equipment
identical to that destroyed by nature gone berserk
and soon after the skies have cleared the highly
intricate facilities of telephone communication
are back on the job thanks to the years of
experience in the established working pattern of
Western Electric and the rest of the bail system
thus three great functional units are inseparably
United in a single service service to mrs. Smith
this then is the story of the making and procuring
of the countless devices that service tools
for those whose deft fingers and technical
skill produce for mrs. Smith the miracle that
is really no miracle at all it is the result of
the kind of team play through which this nation
has achieved industrial greatness out of this
coordinated teamwork our coming new innovations
new progress which will advance telephone service
even more significantly than in the past when
at last they come will mrs. Smith be a little
wide-eyed by the reaching of new milestones
and communication not at all she has learned to
accept such things confidently and complacently
and after all that's just the way it should